donald trump's nightmare is now
potentially
a reality he is in a statistical tie
with joe biden in the red state
of texas in an election which
really could go either way in texas now
i obviously don't have to tell you
if joe biden were to win texas
this will be a historic defeat for
donald trump this will be like something
we've not seen
in a very long time in american politics
but i
also shouldn't have to tell you by now
but i will that nothing is certain and
everyone must vote
so in one new poll from texas from the
dallas morning news joe biden is now
leading by five
48 to 43 now that's leaving nine percent
in the third party or undecided bucket
uh and they could break for the
incumbent donald trump between now and
november and they may well
will they may well do that if you look
at the averages
of recent polling in texas it's not as
bad for trump in the real clear politics
average
it's just a tie in the 538
average trump is ahead by 0.1 percent
so understand that these are blended
averages looking at recent polls
i don't know that the exact numbers are
so important like
if it's a tie in texas versus if trump's
winning by 0.1
or if trump or biden are winning by one
the point is it's close in texas and the
story is the trend line
three four months ago at the start of
the pandemic five months ago now
um trump was solidly ahead in every
texas poll by about five points
that lead has evaporated into what is
now listen we can just say it's tight
in texas now if you say to me david
you've got to bet money who wins texas
in november i'm still betting trump wins
texas and in fact
if you look at the betting market 64
percent of people
are still betting that donald trump wins
the state of texas but 64
is actually quite low historically
because the last time
that a democratic presidential candidate
won in texas
was jimmy carter in 1976
that's 44 years ago so this could be a
historic defeat for donald trump
or trump might suppress just enough of
the vote
lie and claim just enough of an
accomplishment
i guess on coronavirus or the economy to
convince
just enough people to vote for him just
enough people might end up deciding to
stay home
if vote by mail isn't happening in their
state and they feel that it's dangerous
to their health to go out and vote
and he could squeak out another
electoral win now i want to be
crystal clear about something here the
nightmare of trump getting crushed in
november
will be nothing for him compared to the
nightmare
that he has subjected the united states
and the world to
for the last three and a half years and
trump may not have the nightmare of
losing in november
if we don't go vote and we get voters
registered
and we make sure that everybody votes so
this is the
the daily or weekly reminder you've got
to vote no matter what
ask your friends if they are voting and
encourage them to do so
we do not want 2016 all over again
now texas is interesting for another
reason texas is a story
as much about gerrymandering as it is
about
donald trump not doing well when you
look at the districts
texas is red there's no denying it but
texas is much less red than many other
states so
for example hillary clinton got 43 of
the vote in 2016 in texas 43
of the vote for comparison here in
massachusetts donald trump only got 32
percent
of the vote so to put it a different way
hillary clinton's support
in texas was more than a third larger
than trump support here in massachusetts
texas is much more purple
than many other states that are
considered solid red states
the thing about texas is that it is
hugely gerrymandered and when you look
at
the house reality in the u.s house of
representatives when you look at
the districts within texas at the state
level
the gerrymandering that has gone on
there is responsible for texas
seeming much more red than it actually
is because 43 percent for
the democratic candidate in a state that
is
considered to be one of the reddest of
red texas is increasingly purple you
look at places like austin and other
cities it is a changing landscape and
let's see what we can do in 2020 to make
it
maybe the start of the start of um
texas being a swin swing state texas
being a battleground state which would
be
terrible at a systemic level for
republicans as we've talked about many
many times
but assume nothing imagine that
your one vote could be the deciding vote
in your state
if you knew that could be the case you
would sure as hell go out and vote